an African Americans and women and the
japanese-american internment during the
Second World War see all those
interconnections and then see as we look
to the current years of the disability
rights movement the gay and lesbian
rights went the student rights movement
well great well thank you for taking a
few minutes to talk to us today thank
you thank you very much thank you very
much in his new book take this job and
ship it North Dakota senator byron
Dorgan argues that outsourcing and
American trade policies that permitted
are harming the middle class he spoke
about it recently in dearborn michigan
for an hour first of all I'm really
pleased to be here this evening in the
Detroit Dearborn area and it borders
books thank you for hosting me and
second thank all of you for coming I
deeply appreciate you being here and I'm
anxious to talk about a book i have
written i'm really pleased that a former
colleague of mine David bonheur former
congressman David bond yrs right in the
back neighbor would you wave David was a
great congressman and in addition to
that he now is involved with an
organization called American rights at
work so he's writing his own book in a
way standing up for American workers and
I'm really pleased that you're here
tonight David let me talk a little about
this book and what inspired me to write
a book I have not written a book
previously but I had a lot of passion to
decide to put down on paper what I was
feeling about some things that are going
on in this country and so I started
writing an outline and finally finished
a book and I'm enormously proud of it it
will be controversial there's no
question about that but I think it's an
important subject to be talking about in
this country the title of the book is
take this job and ship it now you all
remember Johnny paychecks great song
Johnny's gone now but I'm sure he
wouldn't mind if I use the part of that
phrase and change this a little bit of
it take this job and ship it how
corporate greed and braindead politics
are selling out America does that mean
that I don't have great hope for this
country or great faith in the future
note doesn't mean that at all if I
didn't have an enormous reservoir of
hope and expectation about a better
future for this country I'd hardly be
able
to be involved in public service and get
up and drive to the Capitol in the
morning or write a book like this but I
do believe it's important for all of us
to understand what's happening in
America and what we can do to change it
to provide better hope and and greater
hope and opportunity for the future so
let me talk just a little bit about this
country of ours I come from a town of
300 people in South Western North Dakota
ranching country and grain country I
graduated and senior high school class
of nine students I was way up there and
and I used to go to the blacksmith shop
when I was a little boy Adam Krebs was
the blacksmith you know you don't see a
lot of blacksmiths around anymore do you
but I remember as a little boy walking
to the blacksmith shop and his front
door was always open and he always was
he was just full of dirt and the place
he had a bellows and he had a fire going
and he was heating metal and then he
take the mentally pound it with a hammer
and shape it they would be white hot and
and I remember watching him and look and
looking at how hard he worked and then I
understood a lesson as well if you want
to change things and reshape things you
heat it and you found it a bit so my
hope is that the book accomplishes that
he didn't beat it just a little bit see
if we can reshape something that's going
on in this country on the first page of
this book I talk about a story about
FDR's funeral and the folks that stood
in line working people long long lines
waiting to file past FDR's casket and a
journalist was looking for a story to
try to evaluate who was there and he
walked up to a fella who had waited
quietly his hat in his hands waited
quietly for a long long while and he
said to this working man did you know
FDR and the worker said no but he knew
me who knows America's workers today yes
FDR new workers he understood what work
was about he understood as I understand
there's no social program in America as
important as a good job that pays well
because that's what makes everything
else possible and so what we did in this
country
is we built in a century something
extraordinary and we paint as we did it
I tell in this book a story with James
filer I say James filer died of lead
poisoning he actually didn't he died
because he was shot 54 times James
Fowler was shot because in 1914 he felt
that people who went down in the coal
mines ought to have the right to a fair
wage and a safe workplace in the right
to organize for that He gave His life we
went through a century sorting out what
are the rights in this country and as we
sorted them out we expanded opportunity
and as we expanded opportunity we
expanded the middle class and this
country prospered and now in a very
short period of time a couple of decades
or so we've seen a description of a
different America an America in which
the biggest enterprises corporations and
by the way of the 100 largest economies
in the world 51 are corporations 51 are
corporations 49 our country's bigger
enterprises bigger corporations through
blockbuster mergers they've decided this
it is a global economy and what we ought
to be aspiring to do is produce where
it's cheap and sell here and then run
the income through the Cayman Islands so
you don't have to pay taxes so let me
tell you the story of huffy bicycles
because it perfectly describes what I'm
talking about healthy bicycles twenty
percent of the American bicycle market
made in Ohio for eleven dollars an hour
plus benefits by workers who cared about
their jobs and we're proud of their work
now healthy mice bicycles you can buy it
walmart or kmart sears but they're not
made in America anymore all of those
workers got fired all of them and all
those huffy bicycles are now made in
Shenzhen China they're made by people
who earn 33 cents an hour they work
seven days a week 12 to 14 hours a day
and oh by the way a worker from huffy
told me that as they left their parking
spot from their parking lot on the last
day of work as their jobs were taken
from them those workers left a pair of
empty shoes in their parking space and
it was a way for them
to say to this company you can ship our
jobs to China but you're not going to
fill our shoes what they did as a last
job on existing inventory stock was
changed the decal on the front of the
bicycle which had been an American flag
they took that off and replaced it with
a decal of the globe now I could tell
you that story or I could tell you a
story about Mexican food did you know
that fig newton cookies moved to
Monterey Mexico somebody says let's go
have some mexican food go buy some Fig
Newton cookies I can tell you about the
dancing grapes you know the guys that
dress up as dancing grapes remember
those ads about fruit of the loom
underwear right the day I mean who would
dress up as a grape and dance on
television but they did and so the
dancing grapes danced right out of
America they don't make fruit of the
Loom here anymore they don't make one
pair of levis in America not one I can
tell you about Pennsylvania House
furniture that was the furniture that
you knew was fine furniture
top-of-the-line furniture you know I
didn't think you could do this but they
actually decided to fire all the
Pennsylvania house furniture folks and
move that to China and so they shipped
the wood to China from Pennsylvania make
the furniture and ship the furniture
back and those folks at Pennsylvania
house furniture decided on the last day
of work with the last piece of
Pennsylvania House furniture that came
down the line they tipped it upside down
and they're signed their names on the
bottom of that furniture pride in their
job thinking somebody's going to get
something special the last piece of
Pennsylvania House furniture made here
in this country so now people say well
so what this doesn't matter well I've
talked about manufacturing let me talk
about Natasha Humphreys young
african-american woman who did it all
right went to Stanford became an
engineer went to Palm Pilot to go to
work and her last job was to train her
replacement from India who will work for
a fraction of the cost of an American
engineer one half of the fortune 500
countries from outsourcing software
development so people say well you know
what Byron it's a world economy it's a
global economy you're a Luddite of some
sorts you want to put up
around our country no that's not my
purpose my purpose is to say what's
happening here is wrong did anybody ever
decide that we're going to sign up the
people of my hometown Regent North
Dakota or sign up the people of Dearborn
Michigan to have to compete against
somebody that will work for 33 cents an
hour seven days a week and oh by the way
if somebody complains and decides they
probably ought to organize for a little
better deal you can find them in prison
their new addresses of prison cell did
anybody believe that at some point we
should make a decision to do that the
answer is no absolutely not and so today
we have a 700 billion dollar trade
deficit two billion dollars a day and
that won't stand that won't last it
can't it will grievously injured this
country each day were selling two
billion dollars worth of this country to
foreigners Japan and China have two
thirds of the debt they hold two thirds
of that debt and the question I suppose
for our country and the question that I
ask in this book is what do we do about
all this so we just sit and say well
that's this is the new rule this the new
economy it's the new set of rules
understand it and deal with it what it
will mean inevitably are fewer good jobs
lower income and fewer benefits Alan
Blinder the former vice chairman of the
Federal Reserve Board has said there are
42 to 56 million American jobs that are
tradable or able to be out sourced 42 to
56 million he says they won't all be
outsourced they won't all be outsourced
but all of them will be competing with
others who are willing to work for much
much less and therefore downward
pressure on wages and benefits in this
country and so that's what we face and
Winston Churchill once said the farther
back you look the farther forward you
see so look back a century and ask
yourself where we were and look forward
and ask where will we be unless we wage
the fight to decide what we built here
is worth preserving here no I'm not
suggesting that we put walls around
America at all but I am Telling You the
world ain't flat
don't you believe it for a minute oh the
world's smaller the world smaller
because of the information revolution
and new technology but the world isn't
flat we share this planet with about six
six point three billion people and we
circle around the Sun one half of them
have never made a telephone call one
half of them live on less than two
dollars a day one and a half billion
people don't have daily access to clean
potable water and somehow through divine
providence we end up right here what a
remarkable country this is ben and what
a great country it can be but it
requires us to take action and people
say well you know I feel somewhat
helpless I what kind of action just the
power of one it's always the power of
one in America that we the people
document the first three words We the
People anticipates the power of one one
person casting one vote on one day all
of the power in this country exists
there now I've talked a lot in this book
about companies that have decided
patriotism or to take a back seat in
fact I actually quote some business
executives in here who say patriotism
want to take a back seat I don't believe
that for a minute the this notion that
what we have built is irrelevant is a
notion that is destined to weaken our
country and what we need to do as
Americans at this point is decide what
are the rules what are the rules that we
want to aspire to achieve for our
workers for our business enterprises for
our future to expand the middle class in
this country in the future and I want to
tell you i have spoken in this book
about business corporations who just
made a decision i don't care about the
country i care about profits and i'm
going to produce in Sri Lanka Bangladesh
Indonesia China if you don't like it
tough luck and I'm going to sell in
America and if you don't understand that
it's a terrific thing in your life to
buy a cheaper gallon of mustard or 12
pack of underwear then you just don't
get it well I don't get that now not all
business are like that I want to want to
tell you about one man I've also written
about in the book Robert negley
he runs a company that most of you know
who used to run a company most of you
know it's called rollerblade you all see
people rollerblading right mr. negley
owned rollerblade and that he sold it
and he moved to Florida and about six
months later at Christmas time all the
folks at rollerblade began to open their
Christmas cards from the guy that
formerly owned the company and it
surprised them to open the Christmas
card and to have a check drop out and
the check was the equivalent amount for
per each month that the employee worked
for the company some of them over twenty
thousand dollars but Mr negley said is
this is something I want to share with
you and by the way I've prepaid the
federal taxes on it but I want you to
know something I did really well as a
result of this company I made a lot of
money selling the company but one thing
I know about this company is its success
was because of you you produce the
product you worked in the plant you were
what made this company successful and I
want to share some of this with you what
an unbelievable ethic to understand that
workers aren't like wrenches work is to
be valued you don't use them up and
throw them away and so this book is
about a series of stories some
inspirational some that can be a bit
depressing but it's also a call to
action and I describe what we ought to
do in this country to begin putting us
on a different course I want to leave
you with one and I've talked a little
about that during the question as one
leave you with one other story if I
might because it's it's an important
part of what I believe and this has to
do with a foreigner as do with electro
Wesa you remember him he lit the fuse
that caused the spark that that caused
the yoke of communism to be shed in
Eastern Europe and changed the world let
me tell you about like foessa because it
came to speak to a joint session of
Congress one point and I SAT there
listening to him and of course I now
understand from our history book history
books exactly what he said then he
described a saturday morning in a
shipyard in gdansk poland and on that
saturday morning he was an unemployed
electrician
he'd lost his job because he was leading
some workers in the strike against the
communist government because they
insisted on the right to form their own
destiny and and the communist government
was replacing the repressing them he'd
lost his job an unemployed electrician
on a Saturday morning leading a strike
against the communist government of
Poland the communist secret police
grabbed him that morning and they began
to beat him and they beat him bloody
took him to the shipyard fence and
hoisted him up over the barbed wire and
threw him on the other side of the fence
and he told us as he spoke to that joint
session of Congress that he lay there
face down bleeding wondering what to do
next what he did next was to pull
himself up and climb right back over the
fence right back into that shipyard and
10 years later he was introduced to a
joint session of Congress as the
president of the country of Poland this
was not a business leader not a military
leader not an intellectual he was an
unemployed electrician with uncommon
courage who lit the spark you know what
he said to us he said we didn't have any
guns the Communists had all the guns we
had no bullets the Communists governed
out all the bullets we were armed only
with an idea that people ought to be
free to choose their own destiny workers
ought to be free to choose their own
destiny and he said ideas are more
powerful than guns this country this
country is anchored by an idea and that
idea has been the opportunity for people
to become whatever their god-given
talents allow them to become we have
built that idea through the last century
that describe the conditions of workers
rights the right to a decent wage the
right to work in a safe workplace the
right to organize the right to expect
your employer isn't going to pump raw
chemicals into the air and into the
water and in one fell swoop we are now
told that those who produce can pull
vault over all of that and just move to
Shenzhen and then it's just fine
well that's not fine with me and I don't
think it's fine for the future the
future economic opportunities for this
country and I think it's fine for
American workers I don't think it's fine
for American businesses who are trying
to compete in this marketplace with
others who move their jobs overseas so I
decided to write a book and I couldn't
be happier tonight then to see all of
you come to want to talk about that book
god bless you thank you so I let us for
a few minutes be glad to take some
questions and answers and take some
questions I guess maybe you have answers
as well but let's do that and they have
a boom mic and they would like to take
your questions I should tell you that
c-span booknotes is actually televising
this is evening and so that's why they
would like to use a boom mic to hear
your questions so let me call on you
first sir if we can get the boom mic
right up here and she will be able to
get your question did you have a
question or ma'am and sir has anyone
ever challenged the American our
corporate world using out all the jobs
and we provide the sales they don't sell
the items to China or India so has
everyone talked about the the balancing
of that if you sell ten percent then you
can you can have that but you're selling
eighty percent of your items to American
workers and and letting other people do
it so there is no company there's no
balance there well and that's why we
have a 700 billion dollar trade deficit
this country is so far off track in
deficits in fiscal policy the president
says well we're going to be about three
hundred billion dollars short it's not
true take a look at what the debts going
to be the debt is going to increase six
hundred billion dollars next year the
trade deficit is seven hundred billion
dollars that's 1.3 trillion dollars off
track in a 13 trillion dollar economy
that's a ten percent debt load on our
economy in one year that that's why we
have to get our hands around fiscal
policy and also and especially because
of the ability to retain good jobs in
this country we have to deal with trade
policy and
possibly yes sir right back here if
someone is fired from their $22 on our
job to be and the job is being done with
somebody's making 33 cents an hour
shouldn't there be a difference in law
on price call it a tariff if you will
between what the cost of the product but
the person who made 22 dollars an hour
is making and the person making 33 cents
and health care and the retirement
benefits shouldn't that be tacked on to
the price of goods imported into this
country I think in most cases the answer
is yes and I want to give you an example
that I have in this book about what
happens to us with respect to tariffs we
have we have unbelievably incompetent
trade negotiators let's start off with
that unbelievably incompetent trade
negotiators I've threatened from time to
time to make them dress like Olympians
you know Olympians we put jerseys on
them so this says us a right would it be
nice if a trade negotiator just
occasionally could look down to see who
he or she is supposed to represent this
country let me give you one small
example next year and this is automobile
territory next year China is going to be
shipping cars the United States a cherry
QQ right there they've got a they're
ramping up a big automobile export
industry in China well you know what
we're going to find here when they
export their cars the United States our
trade agreement with China provides that
they will pay a two-and-a-half percent
tariff on automobiles sold in the United
States the same agreement provided that
any US car sold in China would pay a
25-percent tariff so our trade
negotiators signed up to a trade deal
with China with whom we have a giant
deficit 200 billion dollars a year
saying on bilateral automobile trade you
can charge a tariff that is 10 times
higher than the one we will charge I'm
telling you that is brain dead and i
think pulls the rug out from under our
country's economic interest that's the
kind of thing we have to stop and we
have to stop it soon yes sir right back
there who actually writes our trade
policies
is it bureaucrats or Congress and
Congress writes them they actually read
them before they vote on them if they do
vote how the heck can you vote for 32
cents an hour vs. 76 dollars an hour
which one it costs a higher manufactured
person in Detroit well Congress doesn't
write trade agreements regrettably that
the the Constitution suggests that trade
agreements are the sole province of the
Congress trade agreements are by and
large negotiated in secret by the US
trade ambassadors office they go over
some place you know where they're
negotiating now anybody know where
they're negotiating now doha doha now
why do you think they'd be negotiating
in doha so you can't show up and give
them trouble right I mean they find
these corners of the globe and they have
these secret negotiations and they come
back and I guarantee you what they do
when they come back as they provide an
agreement that's pulled the rug out from
under us every agreement that's that I
have seen recently and NAFTA CAFTA you
name it all of these agreements
undermine undermine our interest trade
agreement with Mexico when we started
before that agreement we had a one and a
half billion dollar trade surplus with
Mexico now we have a nearly 50 billion
dollar trade deficit with mexico success
Vice President Cheney says that's a real
success I'm telling you I took you know
I took a rithmatic in a really small
school but I can smell success and
failure and these trade agreements are
failures for the economic interests of
our country in my judgment yes sir wait
in the middle
ah what I'd like to see is number one
that we get a right to vote back again
when they took it away from us when they
had the polling booths and they said
they could do it cheaper that was the
wrong way to go they duped everybody we
need to get our right to vote back where
Congress makes the laws the Senate makes
the laws we decide on if the law is
going to pass or it isn't going to pass
and how much money that log gets that's
number one number two Social Security
since nineteen forty they've been
borrowing money out of Social Security
and not paying it back and here recently
there's telling us we have to pay taxes
on her social security and we didn't
agree upon that that Social Security is
our plan move Congress of the Senate
aren't supposed to make a change the
laws and Social Security we voted on
that when Roosevelt was president and
we've had an agreement you could loan
money the Senate in the Congress could
loan money on a social security and we
didn't have to pay taxes when we retired
they changed that and it they're wrong
they've been making all these changes
without our approval there should be one
secrecy there shouldn't be one penny
coming out of your paychecks for the
purpose of putting into a social
security trust fund shouldn't be one
penny of that that is used for any other
purpose under any circumstance those are
trust fund monies and when they're put
in a trust fund they ought to be safe in
a trust fund let me all right
then we we contributed that and that was
supposed to that's a contribution to the
plan Congress says back then the
Roosevelt well we can't work it that way
we're going to have it so we can vote on
it well but no they they change the word
on that let me just make a point about
the social security all right let's just
well yes let's cover it will cover a
number of subjects here including Social
Security look when when Social Security
was created you get retirement at 65 and
the average life expectancy was 63 now
that works out real well doesn't it
you're not going to have a problem
financing that people are living longer
and better lives now people are living
longer and better lives so some
adjustments have been made but we should
not limit Lee we should not in my
judgment abuse the trust funds that are
collected out of paychecks or abuse the
the contributions to Social Security
they should go into a trust fund stay in
the trust fund I want to make one one
further point because I didn't respond
fully to your situation you asked how
does it all this happen I didn't I'm not
here to be involved in any politics but
but I want to tell you something we come
up short on the votes in the Congress
it's not because there aren't some of us
that don't fight I'm in the district of
John Dingell right now John Dingell is
the guy that stands and fights with me
and a few others but we come up short
and I'm in that I'm in the state we're
in the United States Senate both
senators Levin and Stabenow fight hard
against bad trade agreements so we've
you know I mean I happen to know there's
a difference here and and the only way
we're going to win is to get more people
willing to stand up and support good
trade agreements or insist that we're
going to defeat bad trade agreements
that we believe pulls the rug out from
under american workers that's the only
way ultimately we're going to win yes
ma'am let me get to the microphone to
you
yes I would just like to know how do we
get our country back how do we take it
back from the foreign imports how do we
do this she said how do we how do we get
the country back with respect to import
of foreign goods all the American people
running out to buy a China car well our
country should in our country should
insist on fair trade and let me again
let me talk about automobiles because
it's important in Korea 99% of the cars
on the roads in Korea are Korean cars
that's the way they wanted we sell a few
dodge dakota pickup trucks but then they
shut it down and so 99% of the cars are
Korean cars now in the last year they
sent us over 700,000 cars produced in
Korea to be sold in our country and they
allowed four thousand American cars to
be sold in Korea that's not that's not a
fair situation and we should say to
Korea look fair's fair if we're going to
have mutual trade it needs to be
mutually beneficial and if it's going to
be 700,000 to 400 4,000 rather 700,000
of 4,000 then you try to sell those cars
in Zambia for a while see what kind of
market exists I mean I could give you
story after story about circumstances
where we allow other governments to shut
their markets to us and insist that we
keep our markets wide open to them I
don't want to trade war but I certainly
want to have a trade circumstance that
pulls others up rather than push us down
and the current trade strategy in this
country is to push us down lower wages
lower standards and I don't think that's
what America ought to aspire to achieve
yes sir I have question about that I
think the dilemma of trying trying to be
competitive globally by giving the high
quality product in the ship time it's
very competitive in the cost for the
corporations because competition in the
world it's very high right now and
getting worse so we had like two sides
of the problem once aside the problem of
the
Durkin special middle class losing their
jobs and this corporations staying
competitive in a global because it's
even if it's not the world is flat but
in a marketing almost it is big tube it
ought to be capable to compete with the
rest of the world with your products to
have you share in the marketing and to
stay stronger and to be the leader and
still the leader as longer you add as
long as possible how could you solve
this problem to be to have to have your
products produced inside in the center
time to be competitive of society well
you raised a really interesting question
about the outsourcing not just of jobs
but the outsourcing of our best
technology which we will pay a price for
25 and 50 years from now you know this
issue of competitiveness yes it's a
global economy and I'm not suggesting
that we can retreat on a global economy
i am saying we have every right to
describe the rules by which we
participate as a country we have every
right to do that and should at the
moment the mantra about the
globalization is one that is created by
the corporations because they want to
fatten their profits by producing in
China or Indonesia and selling in
Detroit or Fargo and and in addition to
that by the way i'll tell you one
statistic in addition to that they want
to run their income through places so
they don't have paid taxes there's in a
white five-story building called the
ugly house it's on Church Street in the
Cayman Islands it is home to 12,000 748
corporations 15 story white building
called the ugly house thanks to some
enterprising reporting by David Evans of
Bloomberg 15 story white building on
Church Street is home to 12,000 748
corporation they're not all their
lawyers just set them up with an address
there so they could avoid paying taxes
you pay taxes so too should they yes
ma'am
when Henry Ford just when Henry Ford
decided phased up his workers five
dollars a day he understood that
somebody had to buy his cars along
really being how long do it yet do we
can we anticipate that America is going
to be a really viable market for not
Travis is that what we produce but for
what we produce overseas our
corporations are the corporation's
understand this concept anymore I don't
think so and that's that's what doesn't
add up to me we are we are very strong
consumers and have been for a long while
at the moment we're consuming on a great
deal of credit but you know the question
is what happens when you lose your job
or when the next job you get pays only
eighty percent of the job you had as we
outsource all these jobs what happens
the consumption in this country who
takes those products off the shelf if
you're not working you know the the
economic health of a country is not
measured by what you consume ultimately
its measured by what you produce someone
mentioned to be a few minutes ago about
the national security implications for
our country we outsource almost anything
including some very sensitive critical
technology from a national security
standpoint almost anything is subject
now to say well it's it's the global
economy it's the competitiveness and you
know you if you don't understand it they
say shame on you senator Dorgan you're a
xenophobic isolationists tudes just
can't see over the horizon you know what
look it seems to me that the interest
that can't see over the horizon year are
those that want to fatten the Treasury
in the short term by producing elsewhere
and selling here I'm telling you that
doesn't add up for very long and I think
we're beginning now to see the stages of
that everybody says well there's low
unemployment low unemployment and
everything is just really great you know
a president bush had one of these
meetings a while back and some woman
stood up and and she said you know I'm
working three jobs to make ends meet and
he said isn't that fantastic no that's
not fantastic to have to work three jobs
to make ends meet no that's not
fantastic and you know what we what we
should aspire to have in this country is
people believing that their future is
going to be better than the past parents
believe that the kids are going to have
an opportunity they didn't have that was
always the case in this country is not
now people are very concerned about
what's going to happen with their
children's job opportunities right back
there yes sir sure um you've mentioned
this idea of the framework of rules
within globalization but I think it's
important to realize that the the
framework for globalization has been
intentionally set up um to destroy the
sovereignty of nation states and that it
the rules are run by you know a private
consortium of financial institutions and
the same financial institutions mind you
which in the 30s and 40s are you know
brought in like the financing of the
Nazi Party but I have two questions one
is um what are you and the Democratic
Party going to do to ensure that a
representative of this consortium of
such as Felix wroten who represents Wall
Street he's the guy who actually signed
off on the Delphi bankruptcy and
unfortunately the Democratic Party does
take money from him and the DLC side so
what are you going to do to reject Felix
traulsen out of the party and secondly
if you're if you if you're serious about
this idea of protecting American jobs
I'm sure you've heard of the economic
recovery act it was proposed by
economist Lyndon LaRouche ever and what
are you going to do to actually take up
slightly of retooling the auto sector
for industry you know with due respect
Lyndon LaRouche is spent time in prison
and you know I well look my my interest
is my interest is not rejecting anyone
but I my interest is in trying to find
ways to build a platform for a new set
of opportunities for this country's
future I'm I'm concerned about what's
going on in this country want to change
it I've got in this book a whole series
of recommendations many of which will be
very very controversial I don't suggest
you that one political party is all good
and the others all bad we have two grand
political parties in this country both
have contributed to the well-being of
America I believe that now I happen to
didn't come here as a politician tonight
as a partisan politician I believe
strongly in the party that I represent
and I'm proud of that party but I but I
must say to you again this country needs
to call on both political parties both
political parties should aspire to have
the same result in the end and that is a
country that has opportunity and growth
and provides opportunity for its people
that ought to be what both parties
aspire to achieve and we'd have a little
less partisanship a little more
compromise to get there my understanding
that the union is proposed if they're
being fair labor and environmental
standards of these agreements which we
can't go back into maybe we can that's
one second is that I remember when Dick
Gephardt ran for president he talked
about an international minimum wage and
I wonder is it possible to get these
kind of things these Fair Labor
Standards bear environmental standards
so that we're an even playing field well
there shouldn't be any trade agreements
with any country that doesn't have both
Labor Standards and environmental
standards the absence of both makes
almost any trade agreement an agreement
that undercuts our country's interest we
have had one trade agreement that had
some labor standards and that was the
agreement with Jordan the President
Clinton insisted on some Labor Standards
otherwise none of the trade agreements
have Labor Standards or environmental
standards that are worth anything and
even with respect to Jordan we just had
workers now come from Jordan who tella
these are workers who work in sweatshops
in northern Jordan trucked over from Sri
Lanka to work in sweatshops under
conditions that you would find
unbelievable now there are 250 million
kids working in this world and if they
were working a block from here all of us
would be appalled at the conditions
under which they are working we'd all be
appalled we'd marched down there and
shut the place down I'm talking about
kids that produce carpets and rugs and
who discover that their fingertips have
to be scarred with the with sulfur so
because because the people that are
working them in many cases locked up
that they don't want their fingers to
bleed on the carpets when they stick
them so they it's unbelievable what's
going on and yet somehow this
continues and with 250 million kids
that's almost the population of the
United States of America do we should we
compete with that no I don't think so
should someone in America who's trying
to raise a family lose their job because
they can't compete with with a an
eight-year-old kid that's locked in a
factory someplace the answer is no
that's why our country must take the
lead and say our job is a lift others up
not push us down other yes sir but if
you feel if you'll wait for just a
moment I her join the radio today and
you mentioned that our government
actually gives tax subsidies to
corporations you that shut down their
facilities here and ship them abroad how
what is the even nominal justification
that they give for this how is this
possible right I've tried four times the
United States Senate with amendments to
shut it down I'm proud to tell you both
Michigan senators worked with me and
supported me to do it and couldn't get
it done could not get it done I've got a
chapter in this book that's called hogs
at the trough that describes it that and
more but it's unbelievable here's the
construct if you're producing in
Michigan in dearborn tonight and you
close your plant fire you workers move
it all to China hire some people in
China or Bangladesh or wherever and then
ship the product back here and you you
have actually increased profits because
you don't have to pay income taxes until
you repatriate the income and so you'll
keep it over there and then what happens
is the Congress as this Congress has
done at year ago says you know what
people have income parked overseas let's
give them a five and a quarter percent
tax rate and so the biggest corporations
in America got to repatriate in come
back to this country and pay an income
tax of five and a quarter percent
anybody in this room anybody in this
room get to pay a five and a quarter
percent income tax rate none but that's
what's going on and that's what we have
to shut down I'm just wondering how you
answer the people who bow to the god of
Milton Friedman in his book free to
choose
in this situation concerning trade and
whether or not in fact when you look at
the price differentials brought about by
Chinese trade in fact we are not free to
choose yeah I've heard people on the
talk radio who demean and denigrate
anybody who goes against the Great God
Milton Friedman in his concept the
freedom of tunes it freedom to choose
when in fact I don't have that freedom
thirty dollars versus a hundred dollars
for an American product 30 for the
Chinese you're going to pick the thirty
dollar product every time that's a
tariff in Reverse I think we need to see
that for what it is call it out and
change it I think in your book you talk
to that yeah American consumers have
some responsibility here as well and and
that's an important part of this and I
want to tell you I do have a chapter on
Walmart as a matter of fact but let me
let me let me tell you one other piece
of information do you all remember last
year when JetBlue had an airplane flying
over Los Angeles with a nose wheel that
was sort of crooked and and every every
television station was live on that
airplane as they were dumping fuel it
was a 320 Airbus a320 Airbus and they
flew around and around and around
dumping fuel because that front nose
wheel was askew they wondered whether it
would crash land they brought it down
the front wheel hit the runway and there
was massive smoke substantial flame and
sparks and they rolled to a stop and all
of us were relieved because we saw it on
live television jetblue is a perfectly
wonderful company but did you know that
among other things JetBlue like almost
every other airline outsources some of
its maintenance and jetblue flies empty
320 Airbus's to El Salvador for
maintenance now yes they do they fly
empty airplanes to El Salvador for
maintenance and I ask in the book and
incidentally I bothered to check and the
airplane that flew over Los Angeles had
not gone to El Salvador for maintenance
that wasn't where the maintenance and
that plane was done but the question is
do consumers feel better if they know
when they're flying that a substantial
portion of aircraft maintenance has been
outsourced outsourced to other companies
here outsourced to other countries the
answer I think is no and and I think
that's why the consumer needs to be more
involved to say to these companies you
know something if I'm going to purchase
here are the conditions of my purchase
now I'm I want to sign books for all of
you and I'm happy to answer questions
maybe two more questions I'll give short
answers and I want to sign your books
yes sir you began by saying you were
filled with hope what do you see on the
horizon that does give us hope well it's
pretty good turnout here tonight
whenever you talk about this the
American people i think are way ahead of
the political system people are really
concerned about this that you know why
they have those trade talks in doha
because they had them in downtown
Detroit the streets of this city would
be filled if they had them in Chicago or
even Fargo the streets would be filled
with people concerned about what's
happening so they have them in Doha but
I think the American people are finally
at a point where they're saying this
doesn't add up for this country we want
things to be better for our kids and it
won't be if we've decided we should
educate our kids then have them compete
against people that work for thirty
cents an hour I have hope because I
think ultimately the power of one
prevails one person casting one vote on
one day for whatever they choose with
respect to the future they want and I've
been around enough to understand they
don't want where we're headed they want
a better in a brighter future last
question yes sir outsourcing is part of
the economical problem of America don't
you think that exporting billions and
billions of dollars to the State of
Israel so they can kill our women and
children is part of the problem too
outsourcing is not only for our economy
and for maintenance it's oh it's also
exporting are attracted are straight
wait for me can I finish wait I tonight
that's right what I think about that
well he asks a question that is fraught
with great passion with respect to
what's happening in the Middle East I
don't care where they come from when I
see people die it breaks my heart and
and I we need to find a way without
describing at this moment who's a victim
and who's a villain we need to find a
way to put this back together and sees
the
violence and in my hope and prayers are
that will happen you can't you can't
turn on television these are televised
wars these days twenty-four seven you
can't turn out on the television these
days without having a broken heart about
what's happening we have a lot at stake
in trying to fix what's going on there
have been a lot of in justices a lot of
in justices around the world and
especially in the Middle East and this
country needs to provide some leadership
to fix it let me let me say this to all
of you I I deeply appreciate the fact
that you've come tonight I'd be happy to
spend another hour talking about this
but I know that you I want to sign your
books as well and I want I I believe
that you've come because you feel as I
do that there's there's a lot that we
need to do as a country and it starts
with us it doesn't start with somebody
else it always starts here with us and
so let's let's leave this not with an
admonition that things are going to hell
in a handbasket but with the
understanding that that which is wrong
can be fixed and will if we decide that
we have the capacity in our hands and I
believe we do so thank you very much for
being here god bless you
70 thanks for being a crazy I would like
you in one of these earmarks that when a
company is going to take waitress from
the vertical later wages they should do
it from the chairman of the board to the
toilet start at the top five or ten
percent because they always say lewberty
were all together fine everybody takes a
cut because flight attendants do what
they're told they aren't the guy at the
time saying not going cello reports
Montana instead of Chicago fill my
girlfriend lives there you know they
should everybody should take five or ten
percent people at the top never seemed
to have that sort of problem for they
had no Darren Titan they had a
fifty-four percent increase in salary in
one year the top CEOs anyway thanks for
being thank you ladies get in some gear
Martin somebody is blinking oh that was
my toes are you thanks for coming today
the biggest dearborn not completely
typically I came all this way yeah you
know actually I'm actually going to
Cleveland and have an extra hour some
include the rush a little solid frame
well you'll love that know how it takes
hours to get through it thank you money
to this and I saw you uh-huh uh-huh and
blew my mind thank you I just want to
say if you know people like sometimes
hold a fragility as far as I just want
to say that are you standing on this
issue and talking about if I ever met
carpenter god bless you thanks a lot
thank you very much she says it thanks
hi how are you
appreciate you coming I thanks for
waiting to I know it took allow I'm just
glad that something's taken up by thank
you by mario committee carving on loud
engine noises for financial aid finance
for me yeah
then the Senate is in the house it's the
Ways and Means Committee thanks so much
for kingfish actually you know mrs.
finisher
are you aware of that from HR user them
they're holding hearings in burrito oh
thanks for waiting tonight appreciative
all right how are you it's good to see
you when we listed about the reach
everybody you vote twice a year at the
election was a good move every day bye
bye right thanks five we have thanks for
being here appreciate was a bright Arab
Rita Greta right yeah I'm in
construction ramosan I cannot certain
guys yet but they're trying to I had a
guy in fact in the book of the fella
said that he decided to become a
mortician because he figured
hey
I mean some jobs aren't outsourced about
like a taxi driver you got to see the
background at a snail's driving about 43
million jobs thanks boss i'm so glad to
hear someone in Washington with here
with that attitude I can't believe thank
you thank you
not funny elections tremendous cotton by
Romans and strong sort of thanks for
being wrong I was interesting to talk
about like Ansah because I'm ready
face dose please do it all in people
what you said thanks a lot i appreciate
your Doris delivers to go
ok
oh wait thank you thanks for being
thanks again well thank you it's good to
visit with you before
thanks about your might give you a call
abdom
senator how are you how's your book tour
what's been fun thank you so you haven't
you ate a feel for Perry yeah to Marilyn
ma are that I've never seen a spell this
way is it really yeah i mean i think we
go believe you live here listen thanks a
lot thank you for coming on that
occasion thank you in your hi Bethenny
it's good to see you thanks how are you
all right it's good to see you thanks
for coming and waiting
thanks a lot to be so it's been a
pleasure well thanks a lot Williams good
to visit with you beforehand mrs. Bonner
[ __ ] started electic tactician here a
long time ago oh yeah you must be a nice
guy well there's a lot with a young man
thanks for i appreciate your being here
deathless thank you good luck thank you
and who's this toe she has no my
boyfriend what's your boyfriend's name
Joe no Joe must be somebody right tell
your boyfriend hydrogen
make sure
I hope Saturday at all seven for some
families a person mr. president yeah
well that's my grandson who is it race
back and you started the chain all right
thanks i need you i appreciate your
being here thanks a lot i know i'm a
republican but i don't we beat you okay
thanks a lot for me to be here
thank you uh-huh oh sure it is a terror
signing books thanks a lot thanks for
being here I senator Cory don't be
asking this is my son Robbie and me
Robin
re very proud we need to service i hope
you like the presence of a home you're
on the right track he's hyperventilating
oh man well I'm glad you're here I'm
really glad you came to the fish with me
thanks a lot and why should we need to
dispense more okay thanks a lot mini air
hi Bonnie alright get some air job
outsourced Manila you did sure to
renewable job wasn't working right have
a little peace in the book about they
just discovered that there would not be
as much of a problem or vanilla there's
about a year ago with malaria because
the insects is carry malaria wouldn't
survive the air pollution I don't
believe it and you know the president of
President the Philippines announced that
she wanted to increase the minimum wage
in the Philippines and the carrier
corporation said publicly you increase
the minimum wage we move so this notion
that somehow a company's going to go
overseas and bring their standards up so
it's not the case problem is no the
companies are out there's no job too big
banners on the back to thing
outsourced how are you have you seen
that affects thanks for coming to Google
you hear you on Nick Schultz show
everyone yeah yeah it's and the good
buddy of mine the good work it said
here's a great program doesn't oh yeah
yeah love it we in on 13 10 years son
again live on northern suburbs meet
signal that's a nice job what's
occurring keep up the good work we need
three more people thanks for the dance
to and speaking up for we appreciate
your coming and thank you vidoes enough
I'm good how are you he came here pickin
what's there we're not picking against
just want to complete your attention you
know I'm slam understand I'm pleased
that you came I didn't support an
immediate ceasefire
basically solution for X going on I
appreciate your big here as well thank
you I mean by your book I was going to
pursue bad enough you believe that
Israel has the right to wipe out this
bow uh huh well let me put it this way
if a group like Hezbollah were firing
missiles from across the Canadian border
the Mexican border into this country
this country we trying to find them and
to destroy them having said that it is
it breaks my heart to see what's going
on and we need to find a way and see if
we can well develop a piece that will be
a long-lasting you see you in a soul and
trans that you want me to do more stuff
I'm sorry too what you do you think
until then they have a right to know
they clearly had the right but the
question is is when is enough enough and
and I hope that these ceasefire issues
will be resolved very soon where can i
purchase are you going to detail we were
speaking yeah yeah you can
under